John: Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
It's actually Saturday but we're on our way
to Europe!
We've packed up and we're going to Europe,
but where are we going first, Henry?
Henry: North Carolina boo boo.
John: North Carolina boo boo!
Alice, the sun is shining and the sky is blue
and we're feeling...?
Alice: Alwight!
John: Alright!
And now indeed, Hank, we are in Nashville
where noted American heroes Mom and Dad will
be taking care of our kids for the next week
while we're in Europe.
Mom and Dad's house has flowers and chickens
and goats and grilled cheese with the crust
cut off.
Plus there is a fairy garden.
All around the garden, Mom has installed all
of these tiny little fairies that everyone
can search for.
It's like a scavenger hunt!
And there's a golden doodle?
I think she's currently urinating.
Good job, Cassie!
Way to do that outside- oh it's poop, it's
a poop.
And now having dropped off the kids we return
to the airport to fly to a somewhat less wooded
location.
I have arrived in New York just in time to
get on the flight to Madrid, Hank.
So hopefully I will sleep for that entire
flight!
Nat: Hello!
John: Look who I found!
Here's an observation, videotaping yourself
with your eyes closed is not the same thing
as sleeping.
I continue to find it very difficult to sleep
on airplanes, Hank.
Because there is always a little voice inside
of me reminding me that I am 34,000 feet above
the ground which is a situation that calls
not for sleeping, but for ceaseless vigilance!
Nat: Uh...
I slept probably for an hour.
How you doing?
John: Yeah, not great.
So Hank, there are a lot of ways to deal with
jet lag.
I don't like to judge people's ways.
Our way today is that we're going to attempt
the Dory from Finding Nemo, which goes Just
Keep Swimming!
Took a shower, had some caffeine, changed
clothes, still haven't slept, feeling good,
let's go to a museum!
So Hank, we're now at the Reina Sofia Art
Museum.
Just keep swimming!
Saw some cool stuff by Carl Andre, took one
of those glass elevators I hate while Nat
struggled to remain standing, saw a very good
early Picasso and then looked at people looking
at the great Picasso painting Guernica.
And there was also this great Warhol and in
every room they had film from similar periods
of history, which was a fascinating curatorial
choice.
Nat spent a long time watching this one.
Nat and I have become really close over the
last year and a half and among the many gifts
he has given me is an appreciation for movies.
I used to think of them as lesser novels,
but Nat has helped me to understand that movies
are valuable and fascinating of themselves.
He's a great actor but he's also a brilliant
person and so let me quickly say while his
back is turned, I love you Nat Wolff.
Alright moving on!
So now we're going to go to lunch!
It's, it's... fried bacon.
Okay Hank, Nat and I have to end the video
now because we're so tired and we still have
2 miles to walk, but...
Nat: I'm going to be John when I grow up.
John: And I just hope that I'm Nat Wolff when
I grow up.
Awww!
Hank I'll see you on Friday!
Nat: Ohh, I just got almost hit by a car.
John: I'm glad you didn't get hit by that
car.
That would have been really bad for press.
Nat: [laughs]